okay big breaking news from the second
democratic debate that was held in the
middle of last week and the big breaking
news is basically the debate has had no
impact whatsoever on polling okay barely
anything has moved we now have to post
debate polls and I'll show you the data
in a second just as a reminder my
analysis of the second democratic debate
was that in night 1
it was the Bernie Warren progressive duo
that really won the night either of them
could be said to have won I think they
both did well some people in my audience
saying it was Bernie who did better than
Warren so I'm saying the opposite it was
Warren who did better than Bernie
otherwise the performances were so poor
that I actually had Marianne Williamson
in third place in night one of the
debate night two I believe
Andrew yang stood out and then I believe
that actually Joe Biden did well not
because he said anything particularly
great but because he just weathered
constant attacks from all of the other
candidates other candidates coming in or
most of them anyway clearly with the
agenda of going after Biden it made
Biden particularly as some of those
attacks fell flat
it made Biden sort of seem like the calm
rational guy his politics are to my
right I disagree with him on much policy
but I did think that he came away solid
in that debate
we now have polling from after this
second debate and we will put up on the
screen for you the polling before debate
one the polling before debate - and now
the post debate - polling which are
numbers based on - post debate polls one
from Harvard Harris one from Politico
morning consult averaged and what you
will notice the changes are Biden up
slightly Bernie up the most Warren down
interestingly Kamala Harris slightly
down everybody else basically unchanged
the zeros and ones still at 0 and 1 no
real movement for Andrew yang
technically actually down a bit all
still within the margin of error so
continuing to see absolutely no real
effect for the zeros and ones from
participating in these debates many
them are not going to make it to the
third debate on September 12th and my
expectation is that at least some of
them are going to end their campaigns
once they can't participate in the
debates it is difficult to really
justify continuing in the race unless
they think well I could keep raising
money one way or the other so what's
important to understand now is that
historically at this point most often
the leaders in primary polling become
the nominees but not always okay could
change this year but historically
recently that's the way it's been let's
take a look at that you will remember
that so what we're looking at this is a
November 20 2011 agust of 2019 so we
want to look at the equivalent time
about 1314 months before prior elections
in 2016 Donald Trump was leading the
Republican primary in August of 2015 and
he ultimately was the nominee Hillary
Clinton was leading the Democratic
primary in August of 2015 and she
ultimately became the nominee in 2012
Mitt Romney was ahead at this point in
that Republican primary he ultimately
was also the nominee now some counter
points are that in 2008 you had Hillary
Clinton winning primary polling at this
point in the primary and she ultimately
lost of course to Barack Obama and Rudy
Giuliani was also leading the Republican
primary in 2008 and ultimately lost to
John McCain so I'm not necessarily the
bearer of good or bad news here what I'm
communicating is that recently typically
the leaders in the primary polling right
now end up being the nominees but we
have some examples from the last okay I
mean it was 11 years ago but still 12
years ago at this point sometimes they
don't what I think is abundantly clear
is that there is not a path that I see
for anyone other than Biden Bernie
Warren may be Harris possibly Buddha
judge if he can turn it around but I
don't think anyone below Buddha judge
right now has any shot at being the
nominee if you disagree with me if you
see a way that someone below
the buddha judge level right now could
become the Democratic nominee I want to
hear from you and don't just say well
the polling could turn around and they
could take the lead because historically
that doesn't happen with people polling
you know under 5% at this point in time
but tell me exactly what it is that's
going to happen particularly if they
don't even make it to the debates that
are in just five weeks I want to hear
from you let me know maybe via Twitter
at D Pakman